at each at numbers points during the
mission I asked you guys kind of you
know what was your favorite part of this
or that and and I wanted to have you
share some of those stories and
um after we landed uh we were waiting in
the rocking capsule it was very calm
seized thankfully for my stomach I was
grateful for that but um I was asking
these guys what was your favorite part
Ollie let's start with you what was your
favorite part of the re-entry well I
would like to start by saying it was a
wonderful uh trip with all of you guys
that meant a lot for me and I learned a
lot from you guys and and you are like
my family here so uh it's very hard to
pick one favorite part of the machine
because the whole thing is is amazing uh
but well it was really eager for it just
to feel the launch itself how Dynamic it
is and how aggressive or soft it's gonna
be like and I was surprised after the
main booster uh separated yes the and
and the the the the the uh the rocket
adjusted its pitch and start
accelerating and and all the G forces
like pushing us against the seat it was
so amazing to feel and I was like whoa
the acceleration is it is big it is the
humongous and I loved it I loved every
part of it and I'm really looking to do
it again in the future yeah yeah it's
way different than the Sim huh oh yeah
totally like we did we got trained and
and one thing but the feeling the actual
feeling of it it's totally different
yeah it didn't I mean it was a while
back since we had the centrifuge
chaining where we went through those
profiles but it just seemed different to
me and you know the feeling those forces
was uh I think impressive it was about I
think four and a half G's on our
um during the second stage as we were
accelerating uh it's interesting I
always thought it was interesting you
would get up to 200 kilometers and then
you just starts you know you change your
attitude and just increase the speed
getting up there really fast I mean you
know six thousand uh meters per second
which just is amazing you know to go
from zero to six thousand meters per
second in in under nine minutes that's
just phenomenal feeling yeah and I guess
the way you're just calling every time
we speed up or we go to another higher G
I don't know it felt like the
anticipation and and we were just super
excited for it yeah they were they were
they were obviously excited during that
launch John what was your favorite part
of the launch phase now the launch phase
you know I you know I kind of agree with
Ollie you know when it when it pitched
over when we had separated it at uh main
engine cut off uh when it pit you could
feel a rocket actually adjust his pitch
and of course that's where Rockets were
worked best you know with less
atmosphere to hold them back and the
mvac engine doing its awesome job and it
just went it just took off but there was
one moment which surprised me and it's
at the moment of of the t0 the ignition
you felt the rumble then I just felt the
entire it's like the entire room just
went yeah it just the lift you know it
just you know I wasn't expecting that it
was expect a little slower and then a
propulsion but the whole liftoff phase
was it was was really awesome yeah I
kind of agree with Jones because like in
the same relations we don't really get
to that stage like it's over and that's
it but then when you feel like oh we're
actually going you're going yeah
oh these guys at 25 seconds when we knew
we were going they were all wait
[Laughter]
yeah it was it was really fun and how
about the re-entry what was your
favorite part on re-entry uh well for me
it would be definitely the plasma I
would say
Flames they're reflected on the in the
side windows and it just lighting up the
whole Dragon capsule from the inside and
orange yellowish color which was amazing
to feel and we were feeling we are
almost we were almost freezing inside it
was super cold and the outside is like
so many 100 degrees Yeah three thousand
yeah exactly yeah
and and when I saw the plasma Trail
video uh post Landing oh it was amazing
it's like it's like a shooting star or
asteroid or something yeah
as well yeah right and it felt like we
were in the roller coaster like I don't
know we kept rotating
yeah yeah it was phenomenal yeah John
what was your favorite part of that
re-entry I liked it when the uh when the
mains fired I I had forgotten about you
know line stretch he had to get full
line extension and we've been through
the rocky drogue drag portion and the
capsules of course oscillating and then
we're watching you know the the
altimeter from Main cut and then it
fired and we went back into Free Fall
yeah here whoop here we go yeah okay
and of course as a parachute as you know
a lot about tree fall yeah yeah but it
caught me off guard the person's not
gonna work
no that was a lot of fun how about
during the mission you know we did a lot
of different investigations 20 different
investigations or more and
um you know each of us worked on a lot
of different things what was your
favorite one John what did you enjoy
working on the most uh well yes there
was science and stem I was involved
really heavily in Steam projects
reaching out to classrooms and I so so
much enjoyed that
um yeah it seemed like you had a lot of
fun well I did I really did you know and
I enjoyed it more Morris it went along
we had some great classroom interactions
and and in one particular occasion the
controller of the um of the now the ice
cubes system that provided the comments
also on the other end he came back on
and said wow that was a really fun event
they enjoyed that though
so you know the interaction with with
the classrooms was really surprisingly
awesome and we're still getting flooded
with emails and comments of having they
enjoyed that good that's great
how about you which was your favorite
well I would definitely agree with John
interacting with the student kids and it
was amazing and and to feel their
excitement and their words and how
excited they are and proud of us and how
they are really looking for this moment
and doing the experiments we had like
education on and science experiment with
the kids as well and having them asking
this question like why does it look
different in space and and how do you
sleep and and it was it was so simple
but it was amazing and from the
scientific part it was very important
for me that we did the cloud seeding
experiment yeah which hopefully uh we
are bringing back a lot of benefits from
it and hopefully we can we could develop
new technologies in Earth because it
means a lot for us especially in Saudi
to to fight desertification and to
pursue the vision 2030 that our Crown
Prince has started yeah almost eight
years ago yeah so we need to open up an
umbrella store if you're a successful
[Laughter]
I'd say fighting with you
boxing
yo did you enjoy any of them in
particular you just loved any of them in
the glove box as well in the glove box I
loved starting with the DNA
nanoparticles it was very fascinating
for me just to see the particles form in
front of my eyes
um just to see how the
substances change information and how
the bubbles and the zero gravity helps
with that it was fascinating for me to
even see like the media and how it
behaves and on their response experiment
yeah like I saw all of us very full and
I was like we're only gonna get like 14
record leaders out of that and it just
hit me that because like the viscosity
and how the surface tension works it is
really hard sometimes to get that little
amount and put it onto the cells I don't
know to me it was a mind-blowing
experience just being in the LLC what
was funniest to me was when you were she
was in the LSG and she was had a plate
and it's open on the top and she's
carefully put media in on the on top of
these cells and different substances and
she's trying to slide it into the bag
and I'm like you can turn it over and
she's like no no no it's giving me a
heart attack
so they handed it out to me and I held
it up for her she's like oh
like my brain does not like comprehend
how that works I mean I mean to be
honest I was super uh excited to see Ray
working in the glove box she had a
militant discipline in there like I I've
come by offering her drinks or or food
and she's no she's not giving me
anything yeah she was focused
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah and radio too like me I've never
used a radio before and we just got our
licenses so being able to talk to the
kids back home and just hear their
reactions maybe with the other
activities we weren't able to hear their
responses but with this one we were
super excited just to answer the
questions and to hear them speaking over
I remember during the training she was
super excited to learn the alphabet uh
for bravo charlie yeah like a new
language for her I have to tell you a
story because I was I was on a hand
contact and I just finished coming off
of Europe somewhere and I stayed on and
another language came on which was not
immediately familiar to me and Ray
floated by and said oh is is that that's
Arabic that's Arabic well maybe it is
okay and maybe maybe you can figure it's
yours and she said I answered it in two
words and then the guy came back and
said Ray is that right
and he was waiting for you yeah exactly
the next day I came across at the same
time because that's how orbiting works
and the same guy was there waiting yeah
do you guys uh John and Ollie you know
you have a lot of experience as Pilots
do you think that prepared you or helped
you in any way and what parts maybe did
and did not help you adapt to being in
space Oh yeah for sure I mean mainly
mainly in in the dragon systems because
piloting is about systems and systems
architecture and and having that
familiarity with that and having you
know patience and understanding it you
know prepared me for operations in the
dragon
um and then of course in the ISS it's
full of systems so systems knowledge and
how things work it was important for the
whole mission yeah I mean yeah of course
because and flying you'll learn about
every aircraft you fly in and you have
to know everything about it from nominal
to off nominal and you have to know the
emergency that what could happen and
what could go wrong and how you could
mitigate it as well and that helped me
during the training I think because they
have the the background they have the
the mindset of it and learn that and I
have the perspective as well of it but
flying did not help floating yeah
let's talk floating
we were like monkeys over there
it was it was for me it was a nearly
impossible task you know I said oh this
is no problem we'll just go float around
but it takes like just that exactly in
the mood start talking about physics
and if you're in a hurry you can't help
but do that yeah and all of a sudden
nothing gonna stop you all over the
world
yeah I remember when yeah when one event
when we were live on TV and Ray all of a
sudden she started floating up and she
was talking and she's outside of the
parade what I'm gonna do like
yeah it's fun uh learning how to fly in
space takes takes some time to get
really good well I was surprised that I
mean it didn't take you anything to get
back to it and you were like oh this is
yeah but it's home for you for sure yeah
definitely definitely it feels like home
I you know you have to find where all
the new cable uh traps are and
everything but yeah we had you know yeah
you have to learn some of those things
and with that many people on board you
couldn't go as fast like when there was
only two two or three people on board
you know it's pretty easy because you
can zip around the corners because you
have very few odds that you're gonna
Bang into somebody and so
but yeah yeah it was interesting exactly
yeah
um
so
let's talk about looking out the window
tell me tell me your impressions looking
out the window Ray I hope to start with
um what was your favorite or what what
did you feel about that experience yeah
um to me just seeing that thin layer
that protects the whole world and how we
are supposed to take care of this planet
like with all of our hearts we have all
the systems and the Hardwares and we've
learned all about the contingencies and
how to look after each other like in
orbit but then it doesn't require that
much when you're like inside of that
planet Earth
and I don't know that just touched my
heart and it made me think about every
little thing that we do to Earth to hurt
it and try to
improve maybe our habits the things that
we do
um
being able to see all the countries just
become continents and the continents
become a whole world that we need to
take care of that's the whole new
perception for me yeah loved that that's
really special yeah Ali how about you I
mean it was an amazing experience to
look out the window and see the world
underneath you and it certainly you'll
start to appreciate what you had and
what you have on ground as well it's
like this fragile Globe spinning in the
suspend of space and the Darkness and we
need to take care of it uh luckily the
first night once we got on board we were
lucky to fly over the west coast of
Saudi Arabia and we were super excited
about like we are little kids oh that's
Jada that's Makkah that's other city and
take a picture of them it was so amazing
and and the reaction of the people on
earth when they saw the pictures uh it
was magnificent like it's it's unreal
it's I feel like a dream and and I felt
how the Dream came through and I would I
would love to have for everyone
and we had that same feeling every time
we went over the same cities we were
just super excited every time we see it
it's amazing how about you John what
were your impressions uh you know the
just seeing the Earth you know mainly
over I enjoyed it over the oceans when
the sun was low you could actually get a
sense of the the shape of the globe with
the sun reflection so you had this
marvelous 3D glimmer of of a just a
globe and the cloud layers were there
and you could see the distance from the
clouds to the shadow of the clouds on
the surface yeah and you say anyhow okay
I don't know how how hot clouds so you
could you could have a calibration of
what it was but just the shape was there
just this beautiful and the arc I loved
it I love that yeah yeah just hang in
there they call that blue arc the limb
of the earth and I think that's a
special way to call it yeah yeah and the
visibility that you have you're
recognizing that you're seeing 250 miles
in a straight line yeah and you're
looking at objects yeah there it was
fascinating and remember your advice of
us studying some geography before coming
yeah
[Laughter]
to have a perception of where you are
you know it's the I'm not graded
geography but after you know 600 and
yeah yeah you know I I always appreciate
that you know I could tell when I'm over
you know Northern Africa and the Saudi
area because of the desert yeah because
the reflected light that comes into the
cabin reflects off all that sand and
it's this peachy color and I just love
that that beautiful feeling of warp yeah
maybe not more than I do yeah I know
yeah
I think I was able but I think I'm not
sure if I told you that I was able to
spot a plane flying over the Pacific
yeah I saw the contrail yeah I trailed
the control until the soda
I mean I couldn't take a picture of it
but yeah at least I saw it yeah yeah I
saw a couple of those it was that was
fun yeah sometimes you can see the the
Wake pattern from some big boats too as
well sometimes
at just the right time yeah
yeah your first trip back to the window
to the cupola
uh I really didn't get to spend a lot of
time in the cupola but I had one
experiment in there and you know so they
were we were troubleshooting some issues
and so I was hanging out just kind of
waiting and I got to see a a beautiful
sunrise which uh to me is always amazing
uh and and space sunrises happened
pretty fast and you're going at 17 500
miles an hour toward it yeah
so they happen pretty fast but it's just
really interesting first just the the
slim Blue Line yes the atmosphere and
then you get more and more color in that
Arc as you as the sun comes up
around the planet basically coming into
sight and of course once it gets above
the Horizon then it's This brilliant
glare that you can't even look at yeah
until it gets above the station and then
you can see it
I would have to say one of my favorite
views though on this trip was uh Ollie
and I had got just gotten out of our
suits on the re-entry
so after we'd undocked him before the
actual re-entry part we got out of our
suits for a little while and uh as Ollie
pulled off his suit he's like look the
station we can see the station and that
was so amazing exactly so
um maybe broke a little protocol and
told John and Ray get out of here
[Laughter]
and it's super fast yes yeah well we
were had originally gone yeah and behind
it exactly and we could see up to it as
we were in a lower altitude and going
around it so it was it was very
spectacular I thought special because I
even on the shuttle you know I'd done a
fly around on the shuttle and this was
you know kind of comparable to that and
so it was it was really special to see
the station you know
and it's full Beauty okay so that was
kind of one a very special moment for me
so maybe let's ask see what the media
would like to hear about all right oh
yeah sure okay all right
thank you so much that was such a joy to
watch and listen so thank you so much
for sharing so many great stories I know
that I'm gonna probably watch that video
on repeat just to relive those moments
with you we have some questions from the
media that we want to get to and we're
um excited to hear from them as well so
we're going to start and if you're a
member of the media if you're on the
line remember you can use a chat
function you could also submit your
questions on social media through the
hashtag
ax2 so one of our first questions is
Marcia Dunn from AP she has a question
for especially the three new Flyers that
we have with us
um were there any moments during the
flight where you thought to yourself
yikes what did I get myself into here
this is scary stuff please explain thank
you Marcia
uh well unfortunately or fortunately no
I I never had one of those moments
um we had so much work lined out in
front of us that that was the main focus
and then where to find Supply you know
it was a it was a trip of organization
getting your feet under the ground on
the ground but during the entire trip it
was all about occasionally I would stop
and say I'm in space
how cool is this yeah so you just had to
stop about once or twice an hour and say
why am I in such a hurry I'm in that
space let's sit here and enjoy this
moment yeah but now never any anxiety
about all that no yeah I mean I was
really excited about just thinking that
I'm I'm in here I'm I made it I'm in
space and uh trying to adopt to living
in the ISS and being a witness I never
think is floating is all right I know
there was one thing you guys were maybe
a little afraid of the toilet the toilet
yeah
okay
we're not gonna paint the pictures
[Laughter]
from Saudi Arabia they're asking what
experiments or research projects was
Rihanna involved in drawing the mission
in which the outcome shocked or
surprised her Rihanna oh
well I'd say
I mentioned like working with the with
how microgravity just affects
the solutions and the media and how the
cells behave and how many bubbles you
could get like in one tube or one one
well while on Earth you could just blow
and all the bubbles will disappear of
course you cannot do that in space so
these are one of the things that I
learned but I enjoyed every experiment
that we've worked on especially the RNA
response one it was a long experiment
and it took days and I enjoyed the fact
that each one of us had a part to
contribute and to work on it and we were
like working like a chain and it was
amazing yeah I like that too
absolutely the ground team would you
know because we got ahead of the
schedule the grand team would then have
to rearrange and put different people in
the schedule to make sure that we got
all the data collections on that yeah
exactly and it was really special having
the ISS crew there as well they enjoyed
like working with us on these special
experiments we had the chance to work
with each one of them so it was really
nice I really like like enjoy working
with other people yeah yeah
great we have a question from Robert
Pearlman um here's a few but we're going
to do one for John did this flight match
what you imagined when you watch the
early Mercury Gemini and Apollo
Astronauts fly to and from orbit oh
um well it's the it's the space station
and what I experienced growing up were
men in capsules
you know that we're pioneering and they
hardly knew if they were would survive
in many cases and many of the things
that they were engaged to do had never
been done before on the station we're
there with with a program script of
interactions and things to do so it's a
little different but I was prepared for
the episode of launch and being in space
and seeing the Earth so that matched All
my expectations or exceeded them I
should say in all those cases but my
enjoyment of space flight following that
for since I was eight years old this far
exceeded that in a pleasurable way and
gave me you know such a great feeling
about you know the work we did and and
in continuing you know human space
flight yeah great
thank you
Chronicle
um for Rihanna before the mission you
discussed your experience researching
stem cells on Earth can you describe
what it was like conducting those
experiments in space for the first time
I think you've shared a little bit about
that already during our conversation
anything else that stands out
um I think with the with the stem cell
experiment they were adherent cells so
there they behaved differently than the
other experiments that we've worked on
it was amazing how like Ali would come
to me and say oh they come out of the
microscope and they look really healthy
and really great and then we would move
on to like the next so working with stem
cells let's say on Earth and in
microgravity they're totally different
yeah
hmm thank you um ali um how were your
research into cloud seeding on orbit be
put into practice in Saudi Arabia you
talked a little bit earlier about it but
any real life implications on how
they'll use it in the country well we
are hoping to be able to develop new
technology uh coming out of the research
and then the we did which is we are
trying to figure out what kind of
materials or things or add-ons we could
add it to the formula and maybe make it
more effective and increase the
efficiency of artificial raining and as
you know now it's only 30 percent chance
of of the cloud ceiling that to be
effective but now we are looking we are
hoping to make it more than 50 yeah
that'd be great yes it's gonna be
beneficial for so many countries yeah
absolutely yeah very impressive
um a question for Peggy for Melanie from
WFTV I like to know if Commander is
ready for her next trip to space
especially if I can have a crew that's
great thank you thank you
fantastic
um
Irene klotz is asking a question to Ali
and Rihanna what do you think would be a
good next step for the Saudi human space
program
well we are really looking with this
program to be able to develop or
to attract the most uh Talent we could
by developing a human capital in the
space sector in Saudi Arabia and being
able to conduct our own research
independently in space and uh and also
just increase the Curiosity their
interest for new graduate and the stem
fields which is science technology
engineer and math
how about you ready what do you think
well I like the fact that they have
those exhibitions back in Saudi Arabia
that really resembles the life that we
had on space so I remember kids speaking
about how they were able to sleep just
like Ali using the sleeping bag and just
trying to do experiments trying to
understand how the rocket launches that
really
like brings warmth to my heart to see
that amount of inspiration that they got
from this short Mission so we're
probably looking forward for upcoming
missions of course yeah absolutely yeah
and I will say I really enjoyed all the
content that was on from the Saudi space
commission website that shows a lot of
those centers in play and the dozens
thousands of students and kids and
families that have gone through that so
I've really enjoyed watching those video
videos and the impacts that you all are
having in your country
um we're gonna go to the next question
from the Orlando Sentinel this is for
John schoffner you've had you've had a
hand performing two activities tied to
MIT research but I'm particularly
interested in what it was like to Don
the skin suit what did it feel like
getting it on and off and from a bigger
standpoint what are your thoughts in
being involved with something that could
lead to Humanity's expansion to become
interplanetary well I I love the thought
of doing something as one of my
protocols going forward in this mission
was to engage in products and and
experiments that are to advance our our
role in going to space so that was one
of the things I was most adamant about
you know looking for looking to children
that are aspiring to space and then
helping current technology but putting
that thing on was like you've seen a
caterpillar come out of a chrysalis as a
letter yeah well imagine that butterfly
going back into that thing
it was uh well it goes on pretty easily
generally it takes about 10 minutes
now I know the problem will give you a
long stream to do that but you got to
catch it in microgravity
so it goes on it's quite tight and it
loads you down but it's quite
comfortable yeah once you get it on it
was it was it was good to have it on it
felt good so yeah and you did exercises
with it too for them to collect data on
right yeah we did we had a lot of
resistant bands exercises that we had
demonstrated on we have ground data and
now compared to multiple applications of
the skin suit on orbit and then I just
finished here on on the ground again and
I have another one tomorrow or two days
some repeat performances of that to to
compare the Baseline data so we're
trying to determine a method to for the
countermeasures the effect of being in
microgravity over the long term so that
both long and short so researchers can
go to orbit for the short term and come
back multiple trips and not suffer this
horrible re-adaptation that sometimes
that we do yeah and also in long term to
maybe limit the applications of exercise
that are necessary to help lower that so
yeah yeah I'm happy to be involved it
was it was a great trial run and the
team's doing an awesome job crunching
the data so good
I find it funny and interesting that
every time Jones He put on the skin suit
and he asked me to measure him with a
major tape and then see his height and
he was surprised that he didn't get any
taller and I was like can I measure
myself and I got an inch and a quarter
taller yeah yeah it's interesting like
the the effects of microgravity in each
individual yeah sure
that's fantastic information
um rayana we have a question for ABC
about
um your grandmother I know you talked a
lot about her during this trip
um what have you told your grandmother
about your trip and what are you hearing
from girls in your Homeland and um I
will add something what did she think
when she saw your wearing your earrings
in space Oh well definitely brought
tears to her eyes I didn't want to make
her cry but she was very happy to have
like that moment to see her earrings go
all the way up to space
um and I think her granddaughter too
I think she has more fans than stuff
than that too right now yeah
uh it was a special moment just speaking
to her and she was very happy and
assured to see me every day on TV I
think that was very comforting for her
as well yeah
thank you we have a question from Sophie
Sanchez from cosmic Chicago
um
for Peggy were there any instances of
real-time decision making during the
mission that you had to make for your
team specifically during flight or
Landing
real time
real time you know we were changing
timelines around uh a lot and so we had
to make decisions on who would do which
tasks and as we would you know Slide the
program around to fit the timelines that
we had to to make for some of the
experiments and so I did a lot of help
with that trying to rearrange everyone's
schedule and and readjust yeah as we as
we marched along our timeline yeah
yeah Peggy um oh yeah I have questions
from collect space and from ABC and I'm
going to put them together but um it was
how was your shortest space flight to
date and also your recovery from this
Mission compared to your long duration
missions yeah
so usually you know I adapt quite well
going up into space but coming home
after long duration missions I don't
feel so hot gravity sucks
[Laughter]
I uh on this Mission I was hoping that
being short that I wouldn't have those
negative effects on landing and
unfortunately I did have some of those
negative effects it wasn't as bad and I
recovered much more quickly than I did
after a long flight but they they were
there still so yeah
um but we got we got through it yeah
great
another question for for Peggy we spoke
before the flight about the differences
in training across the three spacecrafts
you have flown aboard having now
experience the power of nine Merlin 1D
engines how would you compare it to a
soyuz or even shuttle and
congratulations to the entire team for
sex successful Mission and that's Jay
Keegan from TLP Network the launch yes
now it's it's very different each of the
vehicles is very different
um the the
shuttle of course had much more thrust
3.3 million pounds of thrust and when
the solid rocket booster is ignited
there was absolutely no question you
were you jumped into the air the soyuz
was much slower on the acid it's got a
very elaborate uh math detection system
that once the thrust equals the mass of
the vehicle then if the it holds it in
the air until then but then it falls
back and so there was a a half a second
where I'm like are we going anywhere
the dragon was much faster in its
response at the initial launch you know
you felt it immediately the thrust and I
felt like the the staging was very
similar uh to the to all in all the
vehicles and every in every instance
where you dropped like the srbs on the
shuttle or that you dropped the solid
boosters on the soyuz and Etc it was all
that that staging where you you know
kind of go into your harness as as you
float for a second you know and what was
interesting on the dragon I thought was
how long it took to build up back up to
1G on the Merlin engine as we are in the
second stage I thought that was
interesting that it took some time you
know probably 30 seconds or more before
we actually built back up to 1G oh yeah
yeah
um thank you Reggie um we have another
question for you from the Houston
Business Journal how did visiting the
space station feel this time knowing
that we're about less than 10 years away
from its eventual retirement
well I think it's you know obviously
it's still going back home to me to go
to the space station so it was very
special to be up there again and be a
part of that that mission and you know I
I enjoyed being a part of it before uh
what's exciting to me about this phase
is that you know we space is changing
it's you know becoming more
commercialized and I'm really excited to
be a part of that and to share that with
uh my crew thank you Peggy and following
up on that this one's for John Ali and
Rihanna having now experienced a week
aboard the International Space Station
what advice would you give Axiom space
about must-haves for the future Axiom
station
okay
uh an easy to operate toilet
a gym you know some form of
um exercise area you know like the
station has that's important we we did
not use the station equipment on this
journey but uh I would have enjoyed the
chance to you know keep things you know
working so of course that yeah yeah Ray
anything to well I think since I have
that crew quarter it was very
comfortable so yeah yeah I don't think I
have any more suggestions
yeah I think the you know if I I think
it's important to have a system of
payloads where you can interface and put
the cables Behind the Walls and that's I
think something that we're trying to
design into Axiom station yeah to make
it still easy to use to do to set up new
experiments because you're going to
change out experiments all the time and
so you need an easy platform to do that
and we have like a pull out thing where
you can mount your experiments and
payloads and do the cabling and then
slide it back in and I think that'll be
a huge asset yeah
thank you so much
um we have
Sophie Sanchez of cosmic Chicago this
one's for Rihanna during the return
Peggy calls out the drug shoot
deployment and we saw you grab for the
handle on your seat can you tell us more
about what was going through on your
head and what you felt at that moment
well during The Sims we really did not
live that kind of
um sensation yeah the sensation of how
the drugs will work so when when you
said that I was like what should I do
now
[Laughter]
it was running through my head and then
to me that was actually the start of the
moment of hunting it was really amazing
I remember I screamed after we we almost
um the drugs almost like opened and how
we felt the rocking and the Turning I
don't know it was amazing to me yeah
it's it's interesting that it doesn't
take that long being in space to where
you know you don't realize how heavy you
are as we were coming in during the
re-entry I said okay guys we're up to 1G
and Ray's like it feels like five
you know it it's because your body very
quickly forgets how much mass is
associated with you and then you know
coming in and trying to lift your arm
during the G's as you're coming in home
uh it's really dramatic I think that
sensation of geez after you've been in
zero G's because you know you know on
the launch 4.5 G's didn't feel as bad
yeah you're relatively adaptive exactly
you started out at one and then when you
go from zero it seems to change your
perspective a lot more about and also in
the shoots deploy
the lateral you know the other
accelerations that you get the spinning
the rocking all of that is new to your
inner ear and your Sensations and so I
think it it feels very dramatic and it's
probably not really if we had done it on
lunch day which we wouldn't want to do
but if we had done it on lunch day I
don't think it would have felt as
dramatic yeah so we're going to do one
last question
um for this is for John from ABC
um Peggy told us that she was assigning
her crew to spending one entire orbit in
the cupola we saw your photos and what
was that experience like and I'd also
like to add was there any other homework
that Commander Whitson gave this crew
well that was a that was a mandate of
course to spend spend time in the cupola
and it was you know probably the most
wise you know you know issue or
suggestion that we had
um and it was marvelous it gave you a
chance to calm down and forget what you
were had been working on instead of
flying in and flying out and you saw so
many wonderful things you saw a sunset a
sunrise during that time you saw so many
I didn't care where I was at that moment
I didn't worry about the geography just
the flight and you just watch this
marvelous thing slide under you in any
direction you looked you saw something
different yeah so you got thousands of
views and it was just a calming moment I
called it the the cool pool of space you
dropped into the cupola and it was you
know the sound changed because all the
fans and ventilation were above you and
you just dropped into this it wasn't
silent but you just dropped into a
different element and the Earth came up
around you and you just wanted to stay
there yeah
and I almost did
so it was marvelous marvelous
so other suggestions
that she gave us
um enjoy the ride
that was um it was a marvelous marvelous
Journey yeah
just to enjoy space just enjoy space
well that is a wonderful way to close
for us to enjoy space and enjoy the
moment it's been an honor to work with
Peggy John Ali and Rihanna over these
months and watching this Mission has
been an honor and a joy to watch them
talk about it and before we close I'm
going to ask everyone if you haven't had
the opportunity axiomspace.com there's
lots of video and pictures of the
mission that this crew took and we'll
have much more content sharing on our
social medias and on their Twitter and
other social media platforms for the
individual crew members if you want to
schedule an interview or have a
follow-up questions please send us an
email at media axiomspace.com that
concludes our ax2 return to Earth press
conference but I want you to stay with
us as we show you some highlights of the
ax2 mission and our favorite moments
thank you shukran and go ex2